[Musique]
avec vous là une phrase bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour fallen à la une de la
presse le discours du président
ukrainien devant l'onu volodymyr et
l'ins kit l'onu qui l'a exhorté à agir
immédiatement contre la russie on voit
les deux élèves qui ont la vue qui
accuse une nouvelle fois la russie de
crimes de guerre et demande désormais
aussi son exclusion du conseil de
sécurité ainsi que la mise en place
d'une instance équivalente au tribunal
de nuremberg pour juger les responsables
de ces crimes
une déclaration le voilà une notamment
ce matin du quotidien britannique the
independent hunt et quelques heures
auparavant rapporte el mundo le
président ukrainien était intervenu
devant le parlement espagnol où il avait
comparé le massacre des ukrainiens à
celui de guernica cette ville du pays
basque espagnol bombardé en 1937 par les
avions italiens et allemands en appelant
je le cite à une profonde réforme de
l'onu afin que le droit de vote ne
signifie pas le droit de mourir elle
relayé également par la presse française
ma libération cite lui aussi volodymyr
zelensky l'onu autorise la russie à
semer la mort photo d'un cadavre
retrouvé à modiin à l'appui c'est à
l'ouest de kiev là où ont été retrouvés
les corps de la mère du village de son
mari de leur fils et de deux autres
hommes une réalité nié hier par le
représentant de la russie à l'onu dans
la droite ligne bien sûr du discours
tenu par le kremlin qui martèle selon
libé que tout est mensonge que rien
n'est vérité que les faits n'existent
pas que les images montrent que les
satellites se trompent et que les corps
bouge s'il est une grande absente de la
guerre en ukraine c'est celle dont la
mission est la préservation de la paix
l'onu qui ne mérite pas de survivre sous
sa forme actuelle selon l'ops le
magazine demande à son tour la
disparition du droit de veto des membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité qui
paralyse une fois de plus toute
l'organisation
la guerre en ukraine qui ravive chez les
bosniens hélène les traumatismes de la
guerre de bosnie herzégovine 30 ans tout
juste après le début du siège de
sarajevo c'était le 6 avril 1992 l
envoyé spécial de la croix qui s'est
rendu à saint avé sarajevo mostar et
banja luka
comment cette guerre en ukraine a fait
sourdre la peur et une infinie tristesse
partout dans le pays l'ancien diplomate
igor davidovitch expriment un sentiment
d'inquiétude et de lassitude il ya
beaucoup de peur de ce qui pourrait se
passer ici or la peur prévient-il c'est
le levier principal qu'utilisent les
nationalistes la communauté
internationale est fatigués de nous les
trois partis nationalistes serbes
bosniaques et croates ouvre des conflits
pour susciter des tensions et gagner les
élections qu'ils manipulent pourtant
nous sommes prêts à une vie commune bien
plus que ce que ce que prône l'élite
politique assure-t-il la russie rappelle
la croix est particulièrement active en
républika srpska où elle soutient le
dirigeant milorad dodik et ses velléités
sécessionnistes
un partenariat a même été scellée avec
la police russe en 2016 et deux ans plus
tard en 2018 déjà des spécialistes ont
alerté sur le fait que vladimir poutine
devrait être à la formation d'une force
paramilitaire dans le pays à la une
également ce matin et qu'elle ait une
hélène la disparition du quotidien
algérien liberté dont le principal
actionnaire a annoncé son intention
d'organiser aujourd'hui une assemblée
générale pour un dépôt de bilan et la
dissolution du titre n'est des
douloureux événements d'octobre 1988
lorsque des manifestations spontanées
contre le pouvoir avaient éclaté un peu
partout en algérie ayant grandi dans le
sens de la terreur islamiste la presse
libre acquis démocratiques charmant
payer est menacée d'extinction la
fermeture annoncée de liberté signe
l'échec d'une époque regrette le
quotidien dont l'édito ce matin tient
lieu donc d'épitaphe 60 ans après son
indépendance le pays pour lequel les
meilleurs de ces enfants sont morts doit
rompre définitivement avec ses démons il
doit laisser place toute la place à la
vie à l'avenir qui ne peut s'écrire sans
la liberté sans le journal liberté sale
temps pour la presse francophone en
algérie slate rappelle que 26 titres
dont près de la moitié en exprime
d'expression française ont cessé de
paraître entre 2014 et 2017
un phénomène attribué à la fois un ordre
politique de plus en plus répressif à un
modèle économique devenue obsolète à la
gloutonnerie effréné des éditeurs mais
aussi au recul de la langue française en
algérie combien d'autres quotidien
francophone indépendant restera-t-il
demain dans le pays avoir pour terminer
avec le dessein de dilemme comme chaque
matin pour liberté avec son humour noir
habituel bientôt le retour de la presse
unique dans les kiosques le journel et
un briquet s'il vous plaît avec une
pensée pour dilemme effectivement hélène
qui nous a souvent fait rire en grinçant
des dents le matin dans cette revue de
presse à nos confrères de liberté
algérie on ne se quittent pas là dessus
elle n'a ce que celle que cette riante
actualité donnerait envie de prendre le
large de partir loin très loin et spa
pauline j'en recommande de jeter ainsi
laïos et où des quais fait état d'
offres d'emploi assez inhabituel alors
c'est vraiment loin très loin puisque
les postes à pourvoir se trouve en
antarctique apporte le cross qui se
trouve plus précisément dans l'archipel
palmer c'est tout à l'ouest de la
péninsule alors parmi les offres
proposées pauline il y à la gestion d'un
bureau de poste et d'une boutique
cadeaux mais aussi et surtout peut-être
le comptage des pins mois et autres
bestioles sauvage pour ce qui est des
conditions de travail il paraît que
c'est basique mais confortable que
l'électricité limites et qu'il n'y a pas
d'eau courante ni accès internet ce qui
signifie une communication très minimal
avec le monde extérieur si vous êtes
intéressé damien pauline vous avez
jusqu'au 25 avril prochain pour déposer
votre candidature mais ça signifie aussi
sans doute une paix royale merci
beaucoup et l'aisne à tout à l'heure
dans paris dira